I don't know how many people play league
of legends in a red dress
so we are running a little late to get
to a dance party that I'm hosting at
Toronto dance salsa the new captain
diuretic over inward late because Nina
Nina decided that she needed to play a
game of league of legends so we're
waiting for her to finish she's here in
her dress and makeup playing rammus and
hopefully she'll be finished soon oh she
just died ok ok let's disco what do you
want to tell everybody merry christmas
merry christmas happy new year she's
very focused even though she's dead
she's buying stuff in the shop ok you're
gonna get a penalty it's ok i'll just
leave it on you're gonna get a penalty
you'll still get a penalty that's not if
you quit you'll still get a penalty how
long is the penalty I don't know this is
my life bump into my life I love my wife
she's very special there she is just
drinking her water by forget ago did you
have a fun game yeah I get well I could
put you on to it four times why don't
you call how to speak with you guys what
you're gonna let me go to the party
alone so you could stay here and finish
your game of league of legends ok it's
time to go you look you look good in
your dress thank you I don't know how
many people put in play league of
legends in in a red dress and full
makeup are not that much probably ok